we're continuing our look at whether or
not Fox News is abandoning Donald Trump
in 2024 the answer seems to continue to
be they're not abandoning him yet
but they've got an ejection an ejection
seat and they could pull the lever at
any time if it looks like things are
going to go the direction of Ron
DeSantis here's yet another example
Stuart Varney interviewed Mitch
McConnell's wife Elaine Chao Elaine Chao
was attacked by Donald Trump for her
ethnicity now multiple times he's
referred to her as Coco chow and what is
interesting about this interview is that
Stuart Varney says I mean months too
late but Stuart Varney says we were all
appalled here at Fox News when Trump
spoke about you that way not sounding
very Fox News like let's take a listen I
want to talk about inflation in a moment
but first former president Trump
attacked you on the grounds of your
ethnicity I wonder if you'd like to take
this moment to respond
well the President says many things I
don't make a point of responding to uh
his comments okay I'll leave it right
there we were all appalled at what he
said and uh it's up to you what you say
in response thank you very much we were
all appalled by what he said
so this is kind of interesting there
there are people making too much of this
you know the first thing is if everyone
at Fox News was appalled when Trump said
this about Elaine Chao in what was the
exact date the very beginning of October
uh it's almost the end of December now
so they hid they kept to themselves how
appalled they were about what Trump said
until mid-December uh so if they were
indeed appalled they they were not super
eager to make it known but this is yet
another one of those you don't really
have to read further into it uh than at
face value which is Fox News is
maintaining a certain distance from
Trump under notice that even since
announcing that he was running in 2024 I
don't believe Trump had like a serious
interview on Fox News I don't even know
if he's appeared at all Fox News is
keeping a respectful distance to Trump
while continuing to have pro-trump and
anti-trump voices from the right on the
channel Fox News doesn't know the
direction it's going to go we know that
the murdochs would prefer someone other
than Trump be the Republican nominee and
ultimately president and they're just
leaving themselves that possibility open
it's not the biggest deal but they just
want to be prepared with an escape hatch
if indeed the tide truly turns against
Trump that's what's going on here let's
not make more of it than it is but it is
something that that's the way Fox News
is approaching the 2024 primary so far
we'll have all of these clips that I
played on our Instagram which you can
find by searching Instagram for David
packman show before you go if you
enjoyed this video and want to see more
please make sure to subscribe to my
YouTube channel you can click the
Subscribe button below or above or
wherever it is on your screen and if you
want to support my work even more
strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description